hey everybody this one's gonna be really
quick this is not actually the first
time I brought this up I've talked about
it on my patreon I talked about on a
livestream previously but let's make it
nice and official in case anyone here
doesn't follow the live streams and
isn't following me or supporting me on
my patreon I'd appreciate it but it's
not required so things are gonna change
a little bit around here in terms of
what goes up on this channel and more
specifically in terms of how frequently
for a while now I have been doing it for
videos per week I am cutting that in
half and going down to two videos a week
now that doesn't mean that everything is
going away here's the plan with this the
idea is that what's gonna stay here is
the overdue Doctor Who review which is
going to become take to Doctor Who
review as I start to get into episodes
that have actually done reviews on
before but I am gonna continue to
rewatch through the quality era and that
will remain on Wednesday where it's
always bit so that stays put and then
there will be another video per week on
right now the plan is Saturdays so that
video will be something that is not
gonna be drastically different from the
sort of thing I've already done but the
idea is that it's gonna give me more
time to work on slightly bigger ideas
and slightly better presentation that
I've generally done if you want an idea
of what I what I'm talking about some of
my more recent videos can actually sort
of point you to the kinds of things I'm
talking about by that I mean my video on
transgender themes in famous movies and
also the 90s comics retrial of death of
Superman
not to say that those formats exactly
are what I'm talking about but if you
watch those you can tell that there was
more time that had to be spent on them
there was more editing involved in the
case of 90s chemistry trials there was
green screen effects to work with
basically the workload was just higher
and I was able to produce something in
that I'm a little more proud of than um
am I just sitting down and rambling in
front of a camera more or less unedited
that doesn't mean that I'm gonna stop
doing that it just means it's gonna move
I've mentioned before that I now have a
secondary channel called break room of
geeks
if you like just me rambling that is
still gonna happen
but it's gonna happen in the break room
and it's the break room is not gonna
have a fixed upload schedule it's gonna
be basically whenever I have something
that I want to talk about that I'm not
gonna base a bigger video here on the
main channel around with the idea being
that my more rambling off-the-cuff
looser stuff that will live in the break
room
whereas stuff that is more polished and
is kind of the premiere content of what
I'm trying to produce that will be here
in Council of geeks so that's the plan
livestream still happened here I twice a
month on Tuesdays every other Tuesday
and the overdue doctor who will stay
here and turning in to take to Doctor
Who review as I continue to re-watch and
then Saturdays new video hopefully of
higher quality production quality and
just something that gives me the room to
stretch out and try and grow a little
bit more as a Content producer so we'll
see what happens I hope you'll stick
with me if you aren't already subscribed
to the break room I would encourage you
to do that because as I said a lot of
the stuff you might be used to seeing
here is gonna start migrating over that
way some of it already has so I hope
you'll stick around as we move into the
next phase of wherever all this takes us
thanks for tuning in and until next time
this very brief update of the council is
adjourned